hello and welcome to this video again
stefan mucke why so we get a ratty
gambit k Bishop g4 let's see this is a
decent line for black I think white has
a slight advantage but it's not a big
issue g6 okay you don't see that too
often I want you go 44 m Wow
yeah so it isn't what does it takes
takes an idea forms that working I don't
believe it and I probably not so it just
allows this okay this bad structure
really doesn't look like a good plan
structure for black I can't have 95
don't know if it is probably it's okay
if you move the Queen I can take c64
porn cause of the 97 fork
okay Quincy for looks like looks
dangerous for the check and Roxy 7 I can
also go d 6 and this may be stronger
threatening looks is seven and opening
up the diagonal black resigns yeah it's
pretty awful oops is 7 yahoo 6 over i
mean ii six you have to do something
else now oh it is just not good also
didn't quite understand why ye six
should be played maybe he was afraid
that I would push all the way through
his six possible but i think i can
cancel I mean I don't think the
sustainer us and maybe maybe now I don't
know this is definitely very comfortable
a wide no but some just a pretty bad pro
instruction and black has no particular
counter play Jim Jim and it's losing
yeah that line is is pretty dangerous
IAM with Bishop g4 I mean dangerous for
black he has to be very precise this is
a relatively good line I think but
usually they play with the e6 and not
with g6 but still he is okay Evie avoid
c6 can also play like that here why does
go into
the night over here and try forever for
data leads to very complicated positions
with all the pieces on the board okay
well thanks for watching